claude lapierre retraités vit seule dans
son appartement de longueuil
c'est des mots très difficile c'est de
se trouver seul ne pas avoir de contact
avec les gens selon un sondage réalisé
pour le compte de l'association
québécoise des droits des personnes
retraitées d'isolement et l'absence de
soins sont au centre des préoccupations
des personnes autonomes depuis 55 ans
les plus percutantes là sont surtout en
rapport avec la qualité de vie de nous
et de nos membres lois qui sont tous des
aînés durant la période la pandémie la
vague
et puis la question d'accessibilité aux
services le gériatre réjean hébert
estime lui que les personnes âgées ont
été surprises et g durant la première
vague
il faut bien sûr est en mesure de
protéger les personnes âgées mais n'a
pas les surprotéger très pop al gharbi
aussi à un équilibre entre la protection
contre le virus mais aussi la santé
mentale et surtout la santé physique des
personnes âgées
claude lapierre ressent d'ailleurs tout
le poids de l'inactivité des fois j'ai
de la misère à me lever à mersin plus
étourdis me sens fatigué mon taux de
cholestérol du moto2 diabète a changé
tout ce qu'il souhaite maintenant eh
bien c'est un retour à la normale le
plus rapidement possible un esprit sain
dans un corps sain yusufzai c'est là
c'est là c'est l'idéal c'est l'idéal
ouais c'est issigeac bissonnet radio
canada longueuil